hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have requested i didn't
have time to cover it since we are
covering the candidates tournament but
now there's a rest today
so i decided to check it out it's magnus
carlsen versus nicole sarina
it's from um well basically the match
magnus carlsen played against
everyone uh in the julius bear challenge
uh and uh i don't know how many per i i
think against 20 participants
and we're going to discuss the standings
and how he did after we check out this
game but
this is the uh i think the uh well the
nicest one and the one that you guys
requested the most so uh let's check it
out magnus has the white pieces
and he opens with e4 we have e5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and the bishop
to b5 now magnus goes for
the rui lopez and here we have a6
morphe's defense with bishop to a4
and knight to f6 now uh attacking that
e4 pawn we have d3 defending it and now
d6 by nihal we have c4
now here usually you'll see c3 which
prepares d4 sometimes in the distant
future but here
magnus wants to i guess uh catch nicole
uh you know off guard and go for
some sort of uh uh well it's it's not an
offbeat line it's a line that
is being played but maybe not that much
at the absolute
top level so here he wants to surprise
him we have c4
uh the so-called dudas variation uh and
now comes
g6 the center is now closed uh and nihal
wants to play uh
bishop to g7 and at some point bring
this knight to d4 and the bishop will
help out
with that very nicely so here we have h3
preventing development to g4 and
bishop to g7 here we have knight to c3
by magnus and now nehal castles
both magnus castles as well and now
there is one game
from 2003 where h6 was played but here
we have knight to d7
and it is now already as of move nine
that we have a completely new game so
let's see how magnus deals with this he
plays a bishop to e3
uh and okay nihal continues with his
plan knights to d4 the knight is now on
an excellent square and of course if you
don't want to
allow it to remain there you have to
capture it which is what magnus does he
plays bishop captures on d4
uh we have e captures and now comes
bishop captures on b7 and this bishop
captures on d7
will uh well will we'll come back to
haunt magnus as you'll see so here
uh you have to go back with the knight
for example 92 then c5 and then the game
continues with
uh black having his pawn structure a
little bit messed up but he has a lot of
presence here in the center
and this is a compensation uh enough so
instead after he captures on d4
magnus goes for a sort of a capture fest
trade uh we have bishop captures on b7
d captures on c3 bishop captures on c8
c captures on b2 now attacking the rook
here
rook to b1 and rook captures in c8 and
now magnus needs to
get rid of this pawn because it's
extremely dangerous so he
has to play d4 uh break at this bishop's
defense of the of the pawn on b2 and
now comes uh c5 attacking the center
here
we have rook captures on b2 and c
captures on d4
and while you could go for knight
captures on d4 you don't really
gain anything just rook captures on c4
grabs another pawn now there's a
a double attack here on the knight and
after rook d2
let's say queen to e7 the game continues
uh where nihal would still be up upon
and would retain a better position so
instead after c
captures on d4 magnus tries rook
captures on b7
uh we have rook captures on c4 and now
comes queen to b3
attacking the rook here but this uh will
not do here
nihil goes rook to c3 now attacks the
queen here
and magnus now plays queen to a4 and
this is now
extremely dangerous queen to b6 was a
bit more resilient but
believe it or not the game is the game
is lost now
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the winning idea for nihal here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
mating attack
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show uh it's uh
rook captures an f3 that's the stuff and
uh
now we understand why the queen was a
little bit better maybe on v6 if you
already went for this line maybe you
could force a trade
uh but now you have to capture back so g
captures on f3 was played now comes
queen to g5 with
check king to h1 and now comes
queen to f4 uh a little bit more precise
but these are blitz games so a bit more
precise than queen to f
uh queen to f4 maybe would have been
bishop to e5 because it kind of prevents
the king from reaching the g2 square
and now you're gonna prepare queen f4 to
queen to h2 checkmate and if rook to g1
attacking the queen
queen f4 now threatening checkmate and
if rook to g3
blocking this now you will not do that
now you go rook to c8 threatening rook
to c1 and
only after for example rook to b1 you're
going to play d3 d2
and it's going to be a very very easy
easy victory for
sarin so here instead after king to h1
queen to f4 was played a bit of a
different move order but it helps magnus
defend
king to g2 now right away and now if you
continue with bishop to e5 rook to h1
and this is actually quite resilient so
instead after king to g2
we have queen back to g5 with check
magnus repeats king h1
queen f4 king to g2 and now bishop to e5
nonetheless he has to
he has to go for it there is nothing
better and then now comes
rook the d1 by magnus again rook the h1
is the way to go here even though it
looks very odd uh
what are you going to do with the rook
there and i mean it's a pretty bad
position for white
problem is uh for example if queen to g5
check king to f1 yes it does seem that
your king is stuck in the center the
rook is stuck here on h1
but after something like rook to c8 you
will play this h4 move and
this is the the problem if rook the c1
check you can always go to e2 it's not a
problem
and um well not much else to be done
here if
queen to f4 king to g to n we return to
this position where the rook is guarding
the h2 square
but now black no longer has access to
the g5 square so
this was a little bit better uh magnus
goes for rook to d1
and now comes rook the c8 and now it's a
it's a bit different uh we have queen to
d7 by magnus attacking the rook
and putting pressure on f7 but it is
defended by the black queen
and now rook to c2 uh bringing the rook
into the attack
even though black here has a force the
checkmate in eight so i'm just gonna
show it
because it's it's very nice uh queen to
h2 check
king to f1 queen h1 check king the e2
now wrote the c2 with check rook to d2
blocking and now this
d3 check idea uh point being that uh
now you don't really have many options
here king captures on d3
now rook back to c3 check you can't go
anywhere up the board you have to go
down the board
so king e2 queen captures an f3 check
king to f1
rook c1 check and now after the rogue
blocks you can play rook captures on c1
checkmate
so it's quite a nice one but it doesn't
really matter
rook the c2 was played the position is
completely winning for black so
regardless
quinta e8 to check king to g7 and now
magnus is without a move but
he did not resign here he instead tried
to
play this on maybe he can still win on
time now you never know queen captures
on f7
uh queen captures uh with rook captures
wow
rook captures king captures and now f4
so he will still try to
pose some problems uh bishop captures
the real captures and now rook
captures on a2 we have rook to c4
and now comes bishop to e3 putting
pressure on the f2 pawn
uh we have king f3 now bishop to c5 and
not much for white to do here we have e5
trying to get rid of the defender of the
bishop
but just rook captures on f2 now this
comes with czech king g3
we have king to e6 and now e captures
and d6
we have rook to f5 defending the bishop
and now
rook to a4 going after this pawn here uh
bishop captures on d6
and now uh we have king to g2 uh we have
a5 advancing that pawn here uh instead
of this
yeah you can't really get the king to a
better square so king g2 with a5
and now rook to e4 with check we have
rook to e5 blocking
and now rook to h4 going after the pawn
here
but now bishop to b4 and uh
there's not all that much you can do
here magnus grabs the pawn there's
nothing better
but now a4 we have rook to b7 attacking
the bishop just bishop d6
rook to a7 getting the rook behind the
pass pawn
and while all of these are principled
moves you are still down a piece so
there's always that so here we have a
three king to f3 we rook to e3 with
check a nice uh crushing blow for uh
uh for nihal and nihal uh saying that
okay if you don't want to resign
then we can end the game like this but
of course magnus did not capture
magnus moved the king rook to g3 with
czech king to h4
and now rook back to b3 so he's still
hoping to
to hold on for as long as possible king
to g5 and
now rook captures an h3 we have king
captures on g6
rook the g3 check king h5 and now king
to d5
uh we have king to h4 attacking the rook
rook to c3 now
uh king to g4 we have bishop to c5
attacking the rook and here i think
magnus just uh pre-moved king f5
uh and here nihal just grabbed the rook
here and it was in this position that
magnus calls and resigned to the game
and a wonderful victory uh for nihal
sareen after 52 moves
uh but in reality the game was actually
over on move 19 when magnus played queen
to a4
and this rook captures and f3 uh pretty
much sealed
the deal so uh it kind of went uh you
know
the wrong way for magnus uh at this
point after uh
he captures on v4 you do not capture the
bishop so this was
uh the slight inaccuracy that led to a
better position
uh and then we just had this uh well
uh like we said queen to a4 uh this
simply will not
do maybe a little bit more resilient
with queen back to d1
guarding the knight but your position is
already worse and here
uh after quinte for uh sarin simply made
the absolute most out of it and won the
game very nicely so he's one of the two
players that defeated magnus in this
challenge
uh alongside um alongside uh
wanderling and uh he uh also one person
who drew against magnus's vince and
kaima
so there you have it uh two losses and
one draw
and all of the other games were won by
magnus so magnus against the challengers
final score 19 and a half out of the 22
possible points so not
not bad uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it congratulations to
uh nikhil saleem for such a such a
magnificent victory against the world
champion
uh i would like to thank tony carbonneau
piotr pagowski yuval blankowski
sinan telichi and pietrotesta for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
uh and whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all i will see
you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day